getting started on youtube
it can seem so overwhelming
do you need a business plan how do you
get financing do i need all the fancy
gear it
can just blow your mind but in this
video i'm going to share
three simple hacks these are the three
things you need to get started on
youtube
right now and if we're just meeting my
name is heather torres
i'm part of the think team and this is
the think q a show and today i'm joined
by my
lovely co-host melissa caputo how you
doing today mel
i'm doing great heather pumped to be
here yeah you know when you get started
on youtube melissa it can feel
so overwhelming you and i both have
started youtube channels several youtube
channels
and these three things that we're going
to share with them today are
critical to getting started and they're
simple but they're not
always easy that's the hook yep
yes so melissa this episode is actually
brought to you by
growth video live which is our live
event that's happening
in september please tell the think
community about
our live yes i'm so excited for this
event
i was just saying earlier today that
every time we have been bringing it up
because it's getting so
close i get like butterflies in my
stomach because i'm excited
it's a tiny bit of nervousness in there
because we're trying so many new things
but mostly just
really excited when we first started out
with growth video live
we knew we had to move it virtual just
for health and safety reasons we're
bringing it
to you guys in your living room but now
at this point after all this planning we
are just so
excited for the opportunity that we've
gotten to try out new features
and new exciting ways to engage and have
games and build community
virtually so we're actually really
pumped at this point that we are
um a virtual conference this year so
september 8th through 10th
we are of course bringing the power with
high level strategy we have
experts in the field vanessa lau
pat flynn chalene johnson we have a lot
of people that are coming in with their
niche expertise um and of course heather
and sean
will be bringing the fire with youtube
strategy
but we also are just really pumped for
the opportunities for community
we have a really cool platform that
we're going to be using for this event
and we're going to have a lot of ways
that you guys can connect to people in
similar niches
that you can plan collaborations that
you can find people have
similar interests as you um similar
things that they're struggling with
we're going to have
competitions because we know if you're
anything like us you're competitive and
you
want to or earn some prizes so we're
going to have giveaways
huge tech giveaways we have swag bags if
you're going to if you're one of our
top level tiers you're going to get
amazing downloads and free items
in your swag bag so we have so many fun
things that are coming
and i am really pumped for all of you
guys to be there hopefully hopefully it
will be there go to grovevideolive.com
and you can join us for as low as 97
that's crazy heather 97 and it not only
gets you the three days of the
conference
but the pre-conference events that we
have that we haven't even talked about
all of those the benefits that we talked
about so
pretty pumped yeah and if you have loved
any of the episodes here
on the think market marketing show over
on our podcast
that is like what the conference is all
about we really just wanted to make sure
you knew
that tickets are on sale right now for
97
and it will come right to your living
room it's gonna be like no other
conference you've ever
seen and melissa i cannot wait to share
all the fun giveaways that are going to
be happening and just to see
so many creators connecting with each
other well melissa i'll have you back on
in just a minute
when we get into the uh when we get into
the q a part of today's show but i
wanted to share these
really quick hacks with you again i said
these
are simple but they're not always
easy now if you are ready to get started
on youtube
let me know in the chat if you're
watching on the replay hashtag
replayfam and let me know have you
started
your youtube channel are you ready to
start are you scared to get started
well this is a question that we get all
of the time
how do i start how do i get started on
youtube and it really is as simple as
just picking up your camera and getting
started but
when you ask that question i know that
you're not actually saying like
tether tell me how i start a youtube
channel cause you can go to youtube and
find that out right
you're asking heather how do i actually
grow my youtube channel how do i get to
the big vision how do i make this thing
a reality i can see it
i can see other creators making this a
full-time living i can see
my potential and being able to help
people not just in my own community but
in communities around the world
how do i do it so it's not necessarily
about how do you get started
but it's really how do you get your
channel off the ground how do you get it
to the place where
like my friend erica on the think
marketing podcast episode
a couple days ago where she just started
and she already has a viral video
how do you do it well i'm gonna give you
the three hacks and the three most
common things that people miss when
they're starting a youtube channel and
number one
number one get your pens ready is know
your stuff you have to know your stuff
meaning
well okay i want to make a youtube
channel but about what
and here is where people go wrong and
hear me i love you i think you're doing
a great job
but if you're making a channel that's
actually all about you
you're missing it it really is about
knowing
your stuff and meaning what what
what niche are you in where are you
helping people what does that look like
do you know
things you know i have a homeschooling
channel here on youtube and
it's a passion project of mine i'd love
to help new homeschool moms but
i didn't just start a homeschool channel
as i started homeschooling
i started a homeschool channel after i
had read 30 books and after i had been
to all the websites and after i had
gone through all the material and i
thought you know what
there's a missing piece right here that
i think i can benefit so
when you think about know your stuff
it's the difference zig ziglar says this
it's the difference of being a
wandering generality you've got to be an
expert at something
now i know you're like heather an expert
i mean i'm just showing people how to
clean their house or i'm just showing
people how to organize or i'm just
showing people how to like
make a budget here's what i need you to
do
think about the word expert a little
different think about it like this
be a trusted friend you know think about
it right now
who is your go-to friend with sports i
want you to think about that person
who's your go-to friend with sports can
you think about them
that's what i want you to do i want you
to be known for something think about
this
who is your go-to friend for like
getting the best deals on a vacation
do you know who that person is that is
what i want you to be
on youtube i want you to be the go-to
friend
that helps someone get over depression i
want you to be the go-to
friend who can allow uh who can help
someone train their dog i want you to be
the go-to
friend okay so i want you to think of
the word expert
a little bit different another one is to
be the leader
are you leading in a certain particular
space in
your company that you're in right now
maybe you're at a company and you're
ahead of customer service
are you leading in that space that is so
critical so
these are ways to think about how can i
be different in my space
the next one is to be the guide you know
when you think about climbing a mountain
you think about going on vacation
i mean i'm thinking about all these
things right now because hello i'm ready
uh when you think about a guide someone
that's like a tour guide
they know all of the different things i
remember when our family my daughter and
i we went to
uh new york and we had our friend alina
there and alina was the guide she told
us
what trams what trams sorry what are
they called what subways to ride when to
get off when to get on
what restaurants were the best go to
this coffee shop don't go to this coffee
shop
oh when you go to this place you want to
get this ticket like be the trusted
guide are you hearing me this is how
you know your stuff you got to know your
stuff
and if you're just making a channel
about everything
then it's not actually gonna break
through it's not gonna resonate
the reason that erica who's on the think
marketing podcast is winning
is because she is saying i'm gonna help
you with your finances
from the perspective of a lawyer who got
out of 200 000
worth of debt okay i can listen if she
just came on and she's like today i'm
talking about hair
and tomorrow i'm going to talk about the
uh the food that i ate and then today
i'm going to talk about
um gardening it doesn't actually help
so i need you to be the person that
knows your stuff all right
write that in the comments right now
number one i need to know my stuff
number two
you need to know the problem you need to
know the problem
these are the three hacks that you need
so number one you got to know your stuff
hack it you've got to know who am i like
what am i helping people with
am i either friend am i a leader am i a
guide am i an expert who am i
the next one is to know the problem what
is the problem
that your target audience has how can
you help them
so when i think about uh my friend uh
tony him and his wife
you know through some uh through some
discovery of different medical things
they decided to go vegan
and through them going vegan they
actually discovered that
wow there's a missing piece of people
like us who
need to hear more about who we are and
how we do this meaning
what's the problem so they wanted to
make delicious
vegan food that you can cook at home
right they want it to be
the people that could help you in your
own kitchen it doesn't have to be a
massive kitchen
it's like using the stuff you normally
have getting stuff at the normal grocery
store and they wanted to help you
learn how to cook so what is the problem
people that are coming
to learning about being vegan they need
a trusted guide they need a friend to
help them and that's exactly what cami's
doing
when i think about know the problem i
think about us here at think media
think media as a company our mission is
to help
people who want to grow their influence
online
what does that mean well we're going to
help the creator we're going to help the
business owner who sees the things
different
we know that their problem is things
like they care about what other people
think and the problem is
they have no clue what camera to get and
the problem is they don't know how to
make
youtube videos and have kids at home and
still do their job
their problem is is that they already
are an expert in something and they
can't figure out how to grow it online
that's their problem so i need you to
know your audience's problem
these are the hacks you have to know so
i need you to write them out what are
they saying what are the words that
they're saying
and what are the problems that they have
all right so that's number one
number two and you need to write this
down what are they struggling with
what are they struggling with what is
the problem that your target audience
has
number three you need to know your
people you need to know your people and
how do you do this
well you don't make a youtube channel
just for you we've already discussed
that you make a channel for
the people you want to help and how do
you get to know them more
i remember what it was like to post
videos and only have a couple views
but you know what i did i made sure that
those people who left a comment
i was going over to their channel and i
was leaving a comment for them
you need to get inside of your community
that you're serving so we look at this
and there's like a big tribe of people
and then there's like a sub-community
you want to be in that sub-community you
want to be talking to them you want to
be involved in what they're involved in
you want to know where they are and you
want to go there
we have a rule here that we talk about
at think media and it's called the 50-50
rule of
content the 50-50 rule of content
means that if you spend four
hours creating a youtube video that you
should be spending
four hours getting that content out and
how do you do that
you get involved in the community you're
in facebook groups you're on other
people's comments
you're watching other people's videos
you're liking things you're
searching on instagram and you're you're
joining the conversation
so how do you break through in 2020 and
beyond how do you break through on
youtube this year
and the years to come you handle these
three things you learn how to do these
three things and again
like i said this is simple but it's not
always
easy because where people miss the mark
so much when they get started on youtube
is they just start making content for
content's sake rather
than knowing who they are who they help
and getting involved in that community
well i hope those tips helped you get
fired up for today's q a session and i'm
going to bring melissa back on
and we're going to jump into some
questions but melissa
you've seen so many creators i know you
coach people here at think media and
think marketing
you've seen so many creators that are
missing this mark
how easy is it to shift into being able
to
handle these things yeah it can be as
easy as just
tiny little tweaks and we were actually
working with
some creators in one of our communities
today in our inner circle community and
we're just talking about
it's little shifts and it's things that
we just have to
really focus on who we're serving and
that's like the big question that it
comes down to
is who you're serving how are you
helping them
and those little shifts that we can make
will really
help um continually making those little
shifts i think is the key heather
yeah so so valuable melissa and i'm
excited for the q a that are that's
coming in
i know if you are here right now make
sure you hit that like button
let us know in the comments right now
where you're watching from and if you
have a question just to help our team
you can use four little uh question
marks
and those question marks will indicate
that you have a question for us
and how many times can i say that word
question melissa that's what i'm going
for
what is the first question
the first question we have is from david
and i'm actually
going to let you um i'm going to let you
pull up this channel if you want to
check that out heather but this is
um david is musician we've actually had
him
on the stream before and he's asking
about
saying that he read he watched the last
um podcast
episode which was an amazing episode
highly suggest
everybody watches it is going to be good
for everybody to see but on that episode
we talk about having a freebie something
that you can give away
and and get people on your email list
and so he's asking like as a musician
what would be a good freebie for him
oh really good question so david i'm
so excited i went back and watched some
of your videos too
you are so good like i was blown away
by how um how unique and how
just awesome your channel is so what is
a freemium again
remember who are you helping so you
wanted to help beginners learn how to do
um flamingo uh we'll pull up your
channel right now
let me get it up here um there we go
okay so you wanted to
uh help people with their um i can't
even get it mel flamingo guitar
so i would here's a couple things um
what are other people doing
so rather than reinventing the wheel a
lot of times
like that's what we want to do as
creators we're like i'm gonna create
something
so cool that like no one's doing that's
the language that that's actually how
you that's right now that's how i sound
when i say things so
uh that's what we end up doing and what
ends up happening
is no one wants it so what i need you to
go and do
david is i need you to go do some market
research everyone listening right now
this is what i need you to write down
market research who and what who are
your top five competitors
big or small doesn't matter and what are
they doing
so like what type of um freemiums are
they giving away
are they hosting 15 minute calls are
they
sign up for my class are they um so
you're doing tutorials and lessons
or is there something you can do prior
to that so here's
a couple things um you can offer a
download
you can offer a free uh class with you
you can offer um maybe uh some audio
maybe you have some way of doing
an audio piece uh that they can download
that would help them walk through the
steps of one two and three
like you have to get creative in the
terms of how you deliver
your free offer but it doesn't actually
have to be ultra creative
in what it is so like what are other
people already buying and how can you
put your own
spin on it that's kind of the best thing
to think about and there's ways that
people you want to deliver that you want
to deliver it in a downloadable
you want to deliver it in time meaning
like getting
them with you like you one on one um or
you can deliver it in an audio format
those are kind of like the ways
that people deliver free content um so
that's what i would suggest
david and yeah my question to you is
what are other people in your industry
doing because
just because someone else is doing it
doesn't mean that it's wrong it actually
means it's proven
and so i would wonder what have you been
interested in and here
is the biggest unlock david here's what
i want you to do and everyone else
i want you to ask your audience
type that in the chat right now if
you're live ask your
audience because melissa the way we get
the most ideas here at think marketing
is doing exactly that we ask our
audience so melissa what are some ways
he can ask his audience
on social media and through youtube how
can you do that
yeah so definitely using your social
media if you have other platforms that
you have an audience on or even if
you're
just building your audience that's a
great way to engage
um the people who are starting to show
interest in what your topic is and so
going through and doing a poll is an
awesome option
and um that's one of my favorite because
actually when it pulls up
and you're doing a poll on twitter or if
you have a youtube community
post option on your youtube channel when
you have those options doing a poll
it's so instinctual people want to click
and people want to engage with it
so i actually think the poll is one of
the best options for getting people
to actually give you feedback so if you
can say like which kind of video would
you like to see and then if you say if
you have other ideas let me know in the
comments and so then they have the
option to give you
um even more feedback of that but that's
like my my number one
tip and it's like so incredibly
effective and we do it here on a regular
basis
we can actually it's even as simple
sometimes as saying like hey what
questions you have
on this topic hey what questions do you
have on lighting what questions you have
about youtube
and we do that all the time as well yeah
and a lot of people
will come back mel and say well mal i
don't really have an audience it's like
my mom and my two best friends and you
know that's kind of like the only people
i have
i suggest you go to other people's pages
and just read through their comments
because the larger youtubers get
the less they start interacting with
their actual uh
comment section and you can find so much
content in there for what people
actually want so that's um
our uh tips for you um david i'm super
excited thank you so much for being here
and being supportive of the podcast
thank you for listening
um to the last episode with erica and we
have more amazing episodes coming
to you just like that like my friend
rachel
she's coming on next week and i cannot
wait melissa for them to hear
about the three types of content they
should be posting on facebook right now
she's at
60 million organic views melissa i can't
wait it's gonna be yeah
he is so good too and oh she's got she
just like every sentence is the fire tip
from her so that's gonna be
so good um i have another question from
yorkshire pod
we have a new video podcast um we just
got onto spotify
what would be your tips for extending
reach when starting a video podcast
heather i thought this would be a great
question because what did we do this
last year
yeah yeah so you didn't know well i mean
i guess you do because you're here but
we started this channel
this year actually we started it uh in
2020 it's a new
channel and then on top of that we did a
video podcast so we do different shows
here on the think marketing
channel and one of those is our video
podcast so how do you increase
reach with your podcast we have a couple
different ways one
you make compelling content that is
search based
on not just youtube but google so
you want to make content and titles and
thumbnails and all of the content that
is
able to be found in search so when
you're just making
great um sensational headlines
it doesn't actually help you get reach
on your video podcast
in search so i highly recommend that you
check out our free class which
is uh at thinkmasterclass.com we teach
you how to get
discovered in search like what does that
actually mean so that's one way
another way is if you know that you have
profit
tied to your podcast um you can actually
run discovery ads in youtube
on your podcast now that's an advanced
thing so i just wanted to throw it out
there as like another feature
um so you know we don't even do this
here yet at think media
because we are going for all of ours
through
organic search based things and i think
that is the most important skill to
actually master first before you move to
ads
but i know here at think marketing we've
had so many questions coming in about
when should i start ads what does that
look like all of those things so i just
wanted you to know that is a possibility
it would not be my first go-to though my
first go-to is
creating titles that are actually being
found
in search based things so in search
based um
uh inquiries meaning people are typing
in something into the search bar
and your uh video podcast is coming up
now
another thing to remember with video
podcast is it's long form content so
another way that you can get discovered
is you take that long form content
you actually chunk out some pieces that
are maybe two to
five minutes long you make those into
instagram
tv uh video you put it on your instagram
and then you allow that to be shareable
content so you want to lead it back
into um people over on instagram going
to youtube to watch
your actual podcast your video podcast
but if you take smaller chunks it can
allow people to get to know you a little
bit more
start to understand what kind of content
you're doing and that can help drive
traffic
back over to your video podcast i hope
that helps
drop it down here and um drop it down
here like this is where they go
what who am i gosh go ahead and put your
link to your video podcast so the think
marketing
family can check it out and make sure
that you
um are always giving the call to
subscribe to the podcast
all right we're gonna actually bring
somebody on to
ask their next question yeah i love
doing this part okay
we're bringing on recovering addicts so
um
oh there you go thanks go ahead and let
us know what
your question or who you are and what
you're going to do thanks for having me
um i'm recovering addict we have a
channel here that is for
alcoholics and addicts to help them
through these obvious tough times
and so what we did is we went live every
night we've we're on our 130th live
stream
and just last week i scaled down to
three lives a week because
know your stuff right i started college
and to get my peer support tech
and now i want to do 10 minute videos to
end my schedule right my schedule's
crazy right now we've got a good
community growing
um and i'm wondering if i should use the
content that i'm learning from college
and kind of make a series out of it and
how to compact that into my schedule to
bust out
videos that'll take off you know and
bring people in
okay so just so i'm clear what was your
name by the way i'm sorry
lt lt nice to meet you um so
just to be clear what you're learning in
college is
tied to what your channel content is
about so it's like you're learning like
psychology
or you're learning something in college
that's tied to it yes like counseling
for drug addicts
right perfect awesome one i just want to
say thank you so much for doing this
work
uh it is something personal to my family
and so i so appreciate you stepping out
and
and being a leader in that because i
know that it's not always easy to do
that and so for me i just want to just
say i want to honor you for doing that
and building community around that
um second i think that 10-minute videos
are good
as long as it's content that your
audience is
asking for so a lot of times this is
what we do as creators we're like
oh something new and shiny this sounds
fun we should do this now right
and our audience is like oh i'm kind of
liking what you've already been building
so here's what i would do i do maybe a
couple test streams like i do a couple
test minute 10 minute videos
um the other thing is this thing as
an entrepreneur that's really hard which
is called patience
so i just want to say that these are two
things and i'm not discouraging you from
doing this but here's a couple things
one you have to also look at the season
that you're in when you start something
is it sustainable that's the first thing
you need to ask yourself so if i'm gonna
add something to my life i'm gonna add
something else
you just started like you said you you
just started going to college which is
a huge life change right if i add
something into my content
is it sustainable because i'm not sure
but is that content tied to a monetary
thing yet or would it just be free value
free value for right now anything i do
online i'm trying to get for free
amazing i love that and so what i would
say is
is it sustainable to be adding that in
now here's how you can do it where you
can just test it
you can just do a series so what we did
over on think media to test before we
even started
think marketing was we did a uh
content creator business series and we
did like
five videos i think it was on the series
and we brought in one of our friends
who's not a video creator who's like
it was kind of a little bit off from
what we were currently doing
and we interviewed him for like four
different videos and we had another
video added on
and we saw that our audience actually
liked it so we were like okay
we are we're on to something it's not
all of our audience likes this it's a
part of our audience that likes this so
we did just a test series so that's
something i highly recommend for a lot
of creators rather than saying
i'm gonna put my stake in the ground i'm
doing 10 10-minute videos
i'm going to tell everyone about it i'm
going to do this you say hey guys i'm
going to do a four-part series
about x y and z or this is video number
one
of a four-part series about x y and z
and then it's just like a little taster
it's like a little appetizer for them
to see if that's something that they're
interested in does that help you at all
yeah absolutely awesome um so excited
so tell everyone so recovering addict
they can go there and what uh how are
you helping people
how can they get value from you so three
nights a week we go through
books like right now we're halfway
through a book called addictive
personality so we go on and teach
relapse prevention and on top of that
we're a bridge to a community that's
here to help you if you are still
suffering you're still you know with
covid and the lockdowns and anxiety
and anything we're just here our
community now follows the sun with
uk and australia being involved and so
24 hours a day if you're struggling
there's always some loving person there
to
just to reach out to him get get a
shoulder to cry on if you need to
amazing thank you so much for doing that
work like i said at the beginning i
am personally touched by the work that
you're doing addiction is something that
is in my family and my husband and i
have had to work through
through um a lot of things around that
and so i just encourage you to just keep
leaning into that community and ask them
what they want like it's
really is like hey guys i have this
series in mind what do you guys think
i'm sure your community is
completely supportive of the things
you're doing um but sometimes when you
start making content changes
they didn't sign up for it and so
they're like that's not what i wanted
i want this and so it can it can
actually hurt your channel if you start
pivoting
too far away from what the actual value
is but
10 minute videos on a series could be
something very easily done
and i suggest because of the lifestyle
that you're in in terms of being in
college and you're working in your
lives like you have a crazy life already
um batching
is going to be a huge thing for you so
sit down change your shirt change your
hat
but make 10 video make you know five
videos at one time
and then you've got those videos in the
can and you're ready to just whip them
out when you're ready
awesome awesome thank you so much for
being on today
wow mel oh don't you just love seeing
all the different ways that people are
helping
just makes me so excited yeah i think it
really speaks too like we talk about
being purpose driven and that our our
community really is
of purpose-driven creators and so i just
love seeing that and
such clear action sometimes it becomes
it's super apparent like wow you have
such a clear mission and sometimes we're
doing it in more subtle ways like
here's my homemaking techniques and like
like
secretly subtly you're helping moms who
are struggling like
you know there's a lot of ways but
purpose driven is our community and i
just love that so much
yes melissa one other thing on the three
tips that we gave this
this when we started this video uh he
knew who he was
he was like hey i'm here i'm just a
leader of the community right he didn't
come out and say i'm an expert in
addiction he's like i'm a leader i
decided to be a part of this community
and help the people the way that i've
you know all those things
um that's an assumption i'm assuming
that so let me be clear and then number
two
he knew what their struggles were they
needed to be connected he said you know
we have a way that we can help you if
you're in this or not in this like
all of those things and then number
three he's listening to his community
that's why he knows that they're
you know that's why he's been creating
the things he's been creating so really
really
awesome to see that he's already on his
way to being a
very successful creator yes all right
let's talk a little bit about
monetization heather we have eddie
coming on with us
next so eddie um let us know a little
bit about you
what your channel is and then what your
question is hey hey can you hear me okay
yes okay great yeah so my name is eddie
uh i have a
reaction channel called newfie reactions
now i know you guys don't do a lot with
reaction channels
but i'm just curious it's been growing
fast like in eight months i've gained
almost
um 15 000 subscribers
and i'm just wondering is there ways to
monetize it because 90
of the content is copyright claimed and
i don't get ad revenue from it
i branched off into patreon just for
people who want to support me and i try
to give them some benefits and
things like that for signing up but do
you have any other suggestions because i
watch all your videos on affiliate
marketing and stuff but i can't think of
any ways to use that for reaction
channels
so i'm just wondering if you have any
other ideas for me yeah a couple things
one i love what you're doing eddie i
think entertainment is something that
people
need and a lot of times you're right we
do just talk about like more the
educational and the informational
but entertainment is still a really big
part of youtube and so yes here's a
couple ways you can monetize
one um one of the clients that tony on
our team works with he works in the
gaming niche so tony helps different
gamers
and a lot of times we hear the same
thing they're like how do i monetize
that other than like the normal gaming
ways right
and so what he did is he said make a
video actually about your setup
because the thing that people want is
they want to be
you also eddie so it will feel like a
different video like it's like well
that's not really what i do
but let me tell you how do you link
monetization to what you're doing
you say hey guys on all my videos i've
been wearing this headset i've been
chilling this chair you guys been asking
about this i'm just going to tell you a
little bit about how i set this up and
how i got started
i guarantee that that video is going to
lead to some
monetization it's not going to be like
crazy oh my gosh quit your
job but that's one way another way is we
have someone in our community
named sean and he does movie reviews
okay so all he does is he talks about
movies all the time
and how he's been able to monetize is
the cool things like you have in your
room
right now like you've got some awesome
figures you've got the wall
i mean like come on think marketing can
we shout out the creativity in that room
it is amazing
well i just i actually just did that i
just created a vlog channel
i say excuse me my second video was that
i gave a room tour i showed my setup
and uh yeah so i might go down that
avenue of just trying to
let him know a little bit more about me
my life and
hobbies and interests and that kind of
thing and what he does what sean does
is he switches things out so the way
that i'm looking at your setup right now
i will notice that poster in the top the
poster in the bottom maybe like
something like that
but then if you switch it up someone
will be like wait that's a new poster
like we see
more than just the person and so a
different way you could you can
shout it out right at the beginning or
at the end hey if you like this video
and you want to join the name your
people i see you so like new
new fire is it newfie it's newfey
because i'm from newfoundland canada so
that's that's
awesome so if you've named your
community
it's like get the merch get the stuff
get the things like that's
all ways that you can start monetizing
with your fans another way with patreon
like you said you started it
but here's where people go wrong with
patreon they just make it like a hey
donate to support me
but what makes patreon amazing and how
people can
really advance in monetization is the
access
that people get to you so you have to
think of patreon
as the actual business model so how can
they go deeper with you
are there exclusive reactions that only
happen inside of there
are there special packages and and you
guys all get on and you discuss
things like what is a way they can get
actual access to you eddie
so that that's how they're paying for um
support for you
yeah i've been trying to give them as
much as i can like uh let them pick what
reactions i do
give them reactions on their birthdays
they'll have voting rights to pick what
videos i do on my channel
awesome um all kinds of stuff so yeah
awesome well
well thank you very much for your help
definitely and eddie uh shout out your
channel so that people can go and follow
you
it's new fee reactions uh just i'm the
only one there you'll you'll find me
it's all purple based everything's
purple
so yeah so awesome well eddie i just
want to encourage you to
keep bringing people positivity make it
super fun
entertainment is so important especially
right now and you're going to go
so like your channel is going to blow up
you just got to keep going
at it and just like erica said it's like
maybe it's the base hit base
base hit and then one that you do is in
a trend that all of a sudden
unlocks it and now your channel blows up
so thanks
thanks eddie thank you very much
melissa reaction channels are so fun to
watch aren't they
no it's it is because i like hearing
other people's interpretations of things
it actually is like really interesting
to me
but i i did want to throw out as well as
you know brand deals as being an option
and something brand deals and actually
all these monetization strategies that
heather talked about
they you can get really deep in the
finessing of those things
and how that actually you know the deep
strategies of it and that's something
that we're actually talking about at
grow with video live we have breakout
sessions
so that if you're saying i'm in this
space and i need
to learn how to do brand deals because
it's one of my best monetization options
we have a breakout session specifically
for you
so that you can get in a smaller group
and get personalized attention
from you know from those speakers get a
little bit more of an intimate
interactions with them and be able to
get that kind of niche knowledge
depending on where you're at in your
journey so i just wanted to give another
shout out to growth video live
because of that the growth videolive.com
is where you can get tickets
because those are the exact kind of
topics that we're going to be going into
during the conference so um i just i
i as i mentioned heather i'm really
excited for the conference and we just
locked in that
um session recently so i'm really
excited to be able to shout it out
are you ready for our next person i am
so ready for our next person mel i'm
drinking some coffee right now what do
you have happening
oh i'm on the water train i need
i'm trying to do more water than coffee
i i agree i'm at that three you know
it's
it's about three o'clock where we are so
i'm like if it goes past
three you know all right so who do we
have next melissa
we're gonna bring on reuben next so only
reuben
um go ahead and introduce yourself let
us know what your channel is and what
your question is hello hey heather hey
melissa
hey hello my name is reuben thank you
for having me on
um so what i do is i attempt to simplify
the process
of growing on youtube for starting
youtubers make it a little bit easier
for them
similar to what you guys do i took a
little bit of a different route starting
now
um so what i did starting out was i i
attempted to do those
tips and tricks on how to grow on
youtube and recently what i've seen is
that
i started doing banner templates so like
free banners free
outros things like that and those videos
are a little bit shorter they're about a
minute long
but they're my most viewed videos so i'm
making more of them so my question is
how can i make those
one minute videos a little bit longer so
that i get more watch time because as of
right now i'm not really getting a lot
of watch time as they're only a minute
long
really great question reuben and thank
you so much for helping
the community you know i think one of
the things that that we see is we're
like oh someone else is already doing it
so i want to applaud you reuben for
stepping up
and putting your voice in the ring also
because we need all different voices and
all different experiences
and i love the take that you have on the
content that you're creating so
here's my advice so you're making
shorter form videos just so we can
educate
other people you're making shorter
videos and you want to figure out how do
i make those videos get more watch time
how do i help people
go deeper so here's a couple things you
can do uh
one you can start going live and doing
banner reviews
that's one way so it's a separate it's
not actually the exact video
but what you can say in the videos you
can say and hey if you want to join me
on tuesdays i go
live and do banner reviews so make sure
you subscribe
join me on tuesday right so like then or
you can say
and at the end of the video those uh the
next card that comes
up it can be a longer video so if you
start creating some of those longer
videos at the end when they get to the
end of your video and a new one pops up
for them to click
you want that end card to be so enticing
that they need to go and click that next
video so that those are two ways
the third way is what we call content
marathons okay content marathons here's
what this looks like
you've already published those videos
right they're like short form maybe
how long one to two minutes how long are
they about yeah so usually my banner
template ones are they're roughly about
a minute long and then the ones where i
go into tips or
range from five to eight minutes okay
great so here's what you can do
uh we know our content really well you
know your content
really well uh we think that everyone
watches everything
right i mean do you agree reuben
sometimes you're like i'm pretty sure
everyone's watched every video on my
channel
right that's what you hope so ellie
that's what you hope so but guess what
reuben just like
us just like you they don't and so
here's what i want you to do
i want you to take your top five videos
about that
about that content topic okay so you're
gonna you're actually gonna make it into
one long video so you've taken those
short videos
and then in between you can either give
commentary
you can you can answer questions um we
have a video that i'll post
inside of the comments we'll make sure
it's in the description of this video
but we did this with my one of my videos
on think media i did a four-part series
about um about how to create a video
with your smartphone from start to
finish
four separate videos they're ranging
between like five and eight minutes long
so same thing they're not very long
but then what we did is we took those
five videos and i
did a new intro i did all
five videos together i inserted a couple
different q and a's between those and a
different call to action at the end and
now i have a
40 minute video on the channel that has
a million views
now that video is four separate videos
also so we got
five videos out of that one concept
and the long-form one is the one that's
getting the most views so i would love
for you to do on a compilation right you
don't have people do that like mash up
of music
right you can put together these are my
three best tips or these are my three
best ones that i've done
you literally just smash those videos
together and you make
one video what do you think ruben no i
think that's a great idea actually just
have a compilation of the banner
templates that i've made make it a whole
long video that
they have more to choose from yeah work
for both of them works for me works for
them
exactly hey reuben shout out your
channel where people can find you and
how you help them
yeah so my youtube channel is just only
reuben just as it sees right there on
the name only reuben
thank you awesome thank you ruben for
joining us today appreciate it
also i just want to add really quick on
that something we just learned how to do
heather
was during those long videos it's like
putting the time codes so it breaks out
you know the video really easy for your
viewers to see but also
google sees that so if you're putting in
your description
the time codes and i believe it's like
you have to make sure there's a zero in
front
yeah zero colon is it the two ones
is it colon yes you said in the
background
it's zero colon colon zero zero and that
shows time
codes on your long form videos so that
they can
um so and then you can name those just
like you make a video
and it comes up on your screen it's
really cool we have a video coming out
on think media soon about it
yeah and so you could like label the
different um templates that you have too
so that people can
can jump around and find those melissa
we just did that with our imovie video
so we'll make sure to link that in the
description below
if you want to learn how to do imovie
nolan one of the creators on our think
media channel
uh he did i think it was three separate
videos or maybe it was like five videos
and then we actually put it together
into one long
imovie movie tutorial so
um there we go tony's showing right now
or on the screen right now you can see
where it kind of highlights on the
scroll bar and it has
a title on it that is from time codes
so that's how you're able to down in the
description
if you see there's different time codes
those are also labeled so that google
can see what is inside of your videos so
that's just another way to hack
the youtube algorithm to get your videos
seen
i love getting to share that because it
was something that actually
one of our viewers shared with sean on a
coffee with kennel
so it's just getting to pass around
those cool tips that
we're learning too as we go i have a
question from
courageous living asking saying that
they have a youtube channel
um they're a business and life coach um
that's their business a
sorry they're a life they have a life
coach
business i don't know why that was so
difficult i got your mail
business got it a life coaching business
and they want to know if they need a web
page as well as the youtube channel um
such a great question and and this is
something
uh that well let me just let me let you
guys know a little bit of secret you
guys want a secret i'll let them know
secret mel
uh we actually don't have a website like
we don't have like a
website guys we have over a million
subscribers 1.25 million subscribers
we're a seven-figure media company we
actually don't have like
one website i take that back we have one
but it's definitely not a website
it's not like a place here's what you
want you
want a place where people can go to go
deeper with you in the process of their
customer journey
okay what does that mean well why don't
you go ahead and bring up melissa
uh or or tony in the background if you
can bring up like think
masterclass.com so you don't actually
need
a full-blown website i i really don't
think that that is what people need to
start
they need a web page you need a one-page
web page
why because you need a place where you
can start collecting
emails so you can grow an email list now
here you can see this is a one of our
web pages
it's built on a platform called kajabi
you can do this on something like
thinkific or teachable or
or any of the places where you can build
um some some simple pages
but this is done on kajabi leadpages is
another page you can do it on
and what you need is a place for people
to go to get the next step in the
journey with you
so it's not just a web page where they
go and it's like about me
and how i help people and all the things
because people actually
don't really care that much about all
those things as much as we think they do
what they want is they want something
specific
hear me they want something specific
they don't want to go to your website
and read all of the cool things
they want one thing so unless you're
going to have a blog
which is a great thing to have then you
actually don't need an actual
web site you don't need that actual like
full-blown built out
pay thousands of dollars for a site you
need a web page what you're looking at
here
is a single web page that leads you in
the next step you click the button
you enter your email and you go to our
free class
that then allows us to nurture our
relationship with our customer
with our community and hopefully they
will become customers
not everyone does and we're totally fine
with that but then we're allowed
then we're able to go deeper in
conversation with them
through the journey so i would ask you
what is your free thing what is your
free next step that someone can go
uh on the journey with you what is the
journey they can go on with you with
something that's free so you can take
that
off the screen but that's what i would
say so a lot of times melissa people
will jump in and they're like oh i don't
really i'm not really ready i don't have
business cards and i
you know i haven't really built up my
website and i'm like
you don't need all that here's what you
need do they need to make a phone call
with you is that the next step in your
life coaching business
do you want to get one-on-one clients
well then your web
page that you do is like hey book a free
15-minute consultation
and we'll see if we're the right fit for
you to chase your dreams and do all the
wonderful things like
figuring out what that is is a much
better step
and that can happen literally people in
the dms of your instagram like
send them the url it doesn't have to be
hard it's not a
hard page to build there's so many
templates out there
but let me just tell you you do not need
an entire website
you need a web page that takes people on
their next step did that answer that one
for you melissa
yes i think that was the perfect answer
because it is
so true that sometimes actually having
that like standard built out website
with all those different components
is is it's not only unnecessary but
sometimes it's just more distracting
like it actually isn't as clear where
people need to go and what they need
that is the
key did you hear that think marketing
that's the key it can be
so distracting because you're like
there's five million things all the
all the things and hear me as you get
larger
yes you can do a website and you can do
those things you can have a blog you can
do all that
but it's just so much work right off the
bat and i would rather you be putting
that
into making content i would rather you
be putting that time into working with
clients like
a web page is not the end all beetle and
we are here to
show you that we have literally built a
multi-million dollar media company and a
million dollar
million subscriber youtube channel with
zero website we have
a clunky website that we never send
people to ever
we don't even put the url out there
because it's so bad
but that is that's how you do it you do
it with one single page to the next step
in the journey
yep absolutely all right let's jump into
a couple
last questions before we end today here
heather
we have something from brimley games i'm
a board
and card game creator which i think is
such a fun
niche i love board games so i'm gonna go
check that out
it's asking is it better to focus on
games that are well known and searched
and have a lot of competition
or the ones that are less well known
with less competition
uh what should you do both
so okay sure heather of course i should
do both
um i would start with the uh i want you
to be known for what you do
so i want you to start with the less uh
less competition
first i want you to dominate in the less
competition and when i say
both i mean are you in this for the next
three to five years
because if you are then you're going to
dominate all of it when you go
to youtube right now and you search best
camera for youtube
the first like 10 videos that show up
are think media why because we want to
dominate that space and we didn't start
with best camera for youtube
we started with uh best uh let's see
like
like best lenses for the canon m50
like does that make sense like best
camera for youtube best lenses for canon
m50 we became known for one thing first
and then we went uh larger so you also
want to just make sure
that you are you're going for both like
what are the best three top games you
know there's so many
ways you can do it where it's not
actually just searching or writing on
the influence of the game
but it's on the larger market of what
people are searching so like
best family games for kids under 12 or
like
best adult games with your friends like
figuring out what that is
um because that would be the that would
be the wider
uh um topic and then the niche like the
buckets would be the actual like games
that you're doing because we would talk
about
this is my hand motions ready everyone
this is i'm a homeschool mom so we
use motions this is your top
this is your niche these are your topics
okay
thank you yes if you did that at home
right now i just want to say
you're awesome okay so that is uh that's
my answer
to your question what does marie forleo
say your a
this is your this is my a to your q
i hope that's not trademarked sorry
[Laughter]
careful heather i know i know i'm like
when you're flagged copyrighted all the
things
okay so we had a couple people asking
questions about that tip that we had
mentioned with the time codes
yes it does help with seo and google
like that it helps
and i say seo search engine optimization
it helps google understand better what's
in your video
and how to serve that up to people who
are searching
so it does increase i mean i can't give
you like stats of how much this is going
to increase traffic to your video
but you're giving yourself a better shot
yeah google serving your video up
um so when you're when people are
googling as well as when people are
searching it in youtube so
um that tip is definitely worth i think
most of us using if you have a video
that has can be broken up into
a couple different questions or a couple
different parts yeah you know i take it
like this not like if you're gonna
prepare like if you're gonna prepare
a gourmet dinner you don't serve it on
paper plates
you know what i mean like like let's be
real like if you're going to serve
something gourmet
it doesn't come on a paper plate you
want to set the table
you want the nice napkins you're going
to get the crystal
glasses right and what does that mean
okay how do you relate that to youtube
you want to do everything you can to
speak to the machine
of google and youtube and say hey
i'm over here i'm making these videos
and they're about this
and i want you to show it to more people
who like videos that i
make that's what you want to do and so
by doing things like
time codes and keywords and descriptions
and good tags and good titles and good
thumbnails
what you're doing is you are presenting
a beautifully
gourmet dinner out at a very nice
restaurant that does not use
paper napkins and paper plates you know
what i'm saying that's what you want to
do when you're thinking
about how you're serving up this
beautiful gourmet dish
to youtube wow heather
that did you get it are you hungry now
mel because i'm hungry that's why i
thought of food that's why i use the
example of tony and his wife cami who
have the
uh the channel about vegan food i'm like
hungry and ready for dinner
when all of the analogies and examples
are food based we know
we know food and homeschool mom here you
go that's what you get
well heather i think um today's session
was so
good we had so many like little um
really
really powerful tips that were dropped
throughout the entire session so if you
guys
um put in the comments for us what your
ah-ha was from today we want to hear
what was the
the biggest thing the most exciting
thing that you got out of today's
training
let us know what the aha moment is and
hopefully
we will be seeing you guys september 8th
through 10th actually
before september 8th through 10th for
our pre-conference meetup calls i mean
there's got to be
they're like part they're like party
parties yeah it's like
pre-growth video live parties is
actually where we're getting the party
started early
we're gonna have those three calls that
have bonus trainings bonus
opportunities to meet and collab so all
of that is getting started in like
a matter of a couple of weeks that's
crazy
so if you guys don't have your tickets
yet grab your tickets so that you're
getting all of the updates and you know
exactly when things are coming up and
you know
what to get excited about and how to
enter all the giveaways and how to get
like
enter for like youtube studio like there
we have
crazy i can't i can't have some crazy
giveaways
happening like i can't yeah like
you think of all the cool stuff we have
on our channel and a lot of that
kind of stuff is getting away we're
trying
so hard not to like give away all the
details because we're all excited
yeah but we have so many of those things
that are coming up and so if you guys
get your tickets now you'll have all the
details coming into your inbox shortly
about how you can join us and how you
can take advantage of all of those
really cool giveaways and games
and tips and extra bonuses that are
coming up with
that event plus the actual event itself
the details for those three days
so i really hope you guys are able to
join us it is virtual
you can join us from anywhere in the
world and you can get it on your tickets
for as low as 97
so i just hope to see you guys there
it's gonna be such an amazing
opportunity to connect
um build community and also just get all
the strategies
so um hopefully grow with videolive.com
we'll see you there awesome and if you
want to watch the next video you're
going to click over
mel's face and that video right there
that's
going to pop up right now you can click
over to watch that video and we'll see
you
on the next think q a bye